[Music]
hello there watching the press preview
a first look then at what is on the
front pages in the next half hour or so
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the guardian columnist zoe williams
and the chief executive
of conservative home mark wallace lovely
to see you both
as ever though to the front pages
starting with the times
which says the government is accused of
killing off overseas travel
following summer holiday rule confusion
the metro splashes on the global police
investigation which has seen brits among
the 800 held
and hordes of money and cocaine
discovered
on the front page of the eye fresh rush
to get jabs
raises hopes for an end of lockdown
ministers hope a
glastonbury style rush for appointments
among the under 30s
will limit the delay in lifting
restrictions
the guardian leads with the chancellor
rishi sunak being open to
a four-week delay to lock down easing
meanwhile andrew lloyd webber says he's
willing to be arrested should the
government try to delay
lockdown being lifted on june the 21st
that's the lead story for the telegraph
outrage as oxford students vote to axe
the queen the daily mail reporting
the students find her portrait
represents colonial history
the financial times reports that just
days after the g7 countries agreed a new
tax
system for the biggest most profitable
multinational companies
the chancellor rishi sunak wants an
exception for big
city banks and the daily star has an
interesting take on the space race
between billionaires
richard branson and jeff bezos on its
front page yes there you have it um
so the guardian columnist zoe williams
the chief executive of conservative home
mark willis are here
welcome to both of you lovely to see you
um
so where are we at is kind of the
question isn't it and what will happen
next week on decision day for for june
the 21st
um the metro um talking about freedom
day which is how the government chooses
to
describe that day june the 21st is in
doubt
as the northwest faces tougher measures
the question now is rising
hospitalizations what happens next
zoe what's your assessment so i've been
keeping a really close eye on this
because my brother-in-law's meant to be
getting married on the 26th of june
and it has been pretty clear for the
last eight days i would say that the
government has been drip feeding to the
sun in the mail in particular
does the hunch that freedom day wouldn't
happen or it would be delayed by two
weeks
um it's quite surprising i think to find
the guardian leading with sunak saying
he was open to a four week delay because
he's obviously there's certainly no way
they would have gotten used from his
camp without his say-so so he's
obviously trying to get
an alternative narrative out so that
when
freedom day actually is delayed he
doesn't get
all the you he's not seen as the hawk
who's trying to
get freedom today maintained as the 21st
of june i mean bear in mind that sunak
has been seen as the person who's always
been anti-lockdowns who's always been
economy first and
whether or not that's fair or not it's
always been seen as him versus hancock
with hancock worried about
infection numbers and soon worried about
the economy
um so i think it's pretty clear all the
signals are going
this lifting of lockdown this final
moment isn't going to happen
what i think remains to be seen is
whether the in delta variant numbers are
so worrying
that the amount of lockdown we've
already had eased
actually gets rolled back and i think
probably that's where the next
attention will go rather than whether or
not we open up on the 21st of june
i mean it's fascinating isn't it to see
what's going to happen and the factors
that are playing into this
mark i know the data journalist renowned
for the ft
suggesting now that hospitalizations are
beginning to follow
the same pattern as the autumn wave
something we don't want to see
the question is whether deaths then
don't because the cases are largely
among younger people
all of this playing into what the
government does next
again same question to you what is your
assessment of what might happen
well ultimately it all comes back to
that famous phrase
data not dates which the government said
was going to be its approach
i think i i remember coming on this show
to argue at the time that they ought to
be
a bit more transparent upfront with
exactly what measures of data they were
talking about
but right now even if even looking at
say
i think john berne murdoch is the data
scientist you would be a data analyst
from the ft you're referring to
lots of other people who are producing
public analysis
really for the first time in a crisis
like this that you can access
um online that's transparent you can see
what's happening
it's a question of working out exactly
what measures
um tell us
what kind of stage we're at in this
potential um
extra wave and that's partially as you
say about
case numbers it's partially about to
what extent is the strength of the link
still there despite vaccination between
case numbers and hospitalizations
and then it's about of course what what
a hospitalization
at this point in the pandemic means in
practice and
most acutely is there still that link as
closely
between hospitalizations and death rates
but also
of course how long is somebody in
hospital for
what is the threshold at which where
people are being admitted
to hospital and as you as you mentioned
if you're talking because of the
vaccination
uh program success as seems to be the
case that
a lot of this growth in cases is
happening among younger people
to what extent does that mean that we're
going we're going to see
different outcomes or the health the
pressure on the health service is
different
and of course what that all feeds to
ultimately is i i don't think it's quite
as
quite the point that zoe said yes um in
that it's not just about rolling things
back
the question is what delay might there
be if
there is a delay how long would it be
for and of course again data not dates
what would the conditions have to be to
eventually
uh carry out that further unlocking yes
as we let's look at the eye as we talk
about um this next bit then
zoe this fresh rush to get jabs raising
the
raising hopes for an end of lockdown and
describes described as a glastonbury
style rush for jabs which i mean for
government is heartening to see but how
much
is the government prepared to sacrifice
the young in respect just of getting
kovid
the prospect of long covered in order to
stick to its dates and
all the bits that that matters for
hospitality the big events you know
whether it's the hampton court flower
show or the or the euros i mean that
there is
there's still a lot at stake isn't there
for the economy here
well the threat to the young is really
two-fold because they're in the active
economy
you know in the in a sense obviously as
you mentioned they might get
long-covered even if they don't become
hospitalized or get seriously ill
but they are also the people holding
down the jobs in hospitality and events
and entertainment and
you know the general kind of business of
the nation and if those jobs disappear
for another season
they did that that is an extraordinary
hit to this generation so
the decisions made around their health
are not straightforward and their health
isn't the only thing that matters
well obviously health is the only thing
that matters but did their health
outcomes have to be balanced against
their outcomes
in you know launching themselves into
the world
obviously there are all the talk and i
think this is really instructive to
remember we were talking so much about
vaccine passports and how unfair that
would be
on the young because they hadn't had a
chance to be vaccinated yet
and the the old for whom so much have
been sacrificed were getting their
passports and going on holidays when the
young who hadn't been vaccinated and
didn't have the money to go on holiday
anyway
were being thrown to the wolves it is
very heartening
to see that they've reached the front of
the queue
so fast i mean it is only june there was
talk in april if it being september
before the 25 year olds would be
vaccinated
so i am really thrilled to see this and
i'm really thrilled and i've seen it in
my own area there so it spawned there's
a
pop-up vaccine clinic and it's got huge
around the block
it's really delightful and you could
there's there's no point gain saying
that and the if we just go back to the
guardian mark
one final thought on you know what every
element of cabinet and indeed other tory
mps who
i mean we spoke to steve baker and and
mark harper today that pressure from the
conservative backbenchers
uh to get this freedom day the
suggestion from the treasury seemed to
be that rishi cena would prefer
a cleaner and clearer separation
than a oh well you know we'll we'll have
freedom day but you still got to wear a
mask
and all that sort of stuff i mean is
that your understanding of where the
argument is
do you have a compromise do you have a
fudge or do you say
right two weeks four weeks it's delayed
well i think as we've seen throughout
this kind of phased process of
unlocking at each different stage this
has been
a you know it's a balanced process the
whole point is that
as we as we were all learning this
jargon
uh a year and a bit ago the idea that
you've got to some degree an r
budget as it were there are some things
that you can do
and i think um you know from the
treasury's point of view
for example um there's a bit of a false
dichotomy the idea that it's either
lock down or protect the economy the
fact is that
letting this thing get out of control um
you know even worse or again um
you know that's bad for the economy in
in itself for obvious reasons because
you end up then having to say more
severe measures further down the line
but you know perfectly justifiably
people are saying well
given uh exactly as zoe just said the
pain that people
have suffered the the huge impact in
terms
of uh on people's jobs on people's
mental health in terms of children's
education
um and of course the the in pure cash
terms the huge amount of money that's
been thrown
at uh trying to get everybody through
this process
for perfectly justifiable reasons people
aren't going to keep looking so actually
is there an opportunity to do anything
at least to try to alleviate some of
those impacts
earlier and to try to get at least
to release some benefit from the the
vaccine roll out and
that really is why it's so heartening to
see all this nonsense that some people
have been saying for months that the
young wouldn't be interested in vaccines
or
they're gonna have to be bribed with
stickers on tinder
or whatever whatever it might be the
fact is that people uh
young people just like anybody else want
this vaccine to protect themselves
and to protect others and help all of us
get out of this and
that ultimately even with the the delta
variant
um getting vaccinations done uh in large
numbers as soon as possible
is the way to get past that now we want
the lotteries that some u.s states are
offering don't we want a bit more than a
sticker i have to say
um zoey we're gonna we're gonna park
that for now no doubt we will have lots
in the coming days on that
uh everyone's watching and waiting
certainly but let's go to the metro uh
you're tricked
um ocg as we all know from line of duty
fan
groups the organized crime groups have
have had it haven't they what a story
it is an extraordinary story and i sort
of suspect them
of having waited until they had a huge
tranche
of successes before they actually busted
the ring because when you
look at the amount they got you know the
amount of money that would seize the
amount of cocaine that was seized the
amount of
sheer criminal transaction that was both
halted and caught red-handed you do
think this is an extraordinary
achievement um
obviously like anything this is
it's going to be some days before we
know exactly who's been arrested
and i think this story is going to get
more and more exciting as you can
trace the separate organized crime gangs
back to
areas that you might know a bit more
about yes and actually owning an
encrypted app
um puts them in fear of all future apps
they might use for that purpose don't
they
uh the criminals um fascinating stuff
anyway front page of the metro there
thank you for now plenty more still to
come including the perils of upsetting
your builder
we will pitch through the rubble of that
after the break
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now are the
guardian columnist zoe williams
and the chief executive of conservative
home mark wallace welcome back to both
of you
let's go to a story which spoke in the
front pages of both the daily mail
and the times uh which is that students
at modeling college oxford have decided
to
remove a picture of the queen and
gavin williamson mark has stepped in
yes and this this is yet another one of
those kind of eye-rolling stories
of um somewhat ludicrous uh
excess of various different universities
in this case modern college
oxford but it strikes me when you see
these stories it used to be the case
that
we'd all kind of roll our eyes and shake
our heads about it and say oh well you
know these these kind of
attitudes to life won't survive contact
with the real world in a real workplace
but actually that's turned out to be
completely wrong and what we've seen is
that
um because student union uh absurd
politics like this have graduated into
the real world
it turns out that quite a lot of
workplaces and even some publishers
there even some newspapers have them
have fallen victim to the idea that
you set what's acceptable by the
standard of who in the room is most
easily offended
which is why i think it does matter
interestingly the president of maudlin
college
zoe has done a great stream of tweets
about this suggesting that these
graduate students
a few years ago had actually bought this
print of a photo of the queen
and they vote to put it up they voted to
put it down they fully
encourage free speech and political
debate and the right to
these graduate students autonomy um
meanwhile the photo will be safely
stored they might vote to put it up
again maybe they won't
being a student is about more than
studying it's about exploring and
debating ideas
it's sometimes about provoking the older
generation looks like
that isn't so hard to do these days she
has said
but it's also i mean if you think about
it it's what has always happened in
student unions
i mean it is an exercise in your nascent
democratic agency
and people have debates and
i doubt there's ever been a debate won
or lost in any student union ever
that a 45 year old passing it
would look at and say yes i really think
this was an important thing
and the right outcome has been set you
know
it is an exercise in democratic
engagement what i find
worrying is nothing to do with the
students and nothing to do with the
queen
what i find worrying is that gavin
williamson
would have time to weigh in on this
when apparently he doesn't have time to
actually
sort out a level results or to have gcse
results sort out catch up schooling
engage honestly with teachers unions he
doesn't actually have time to be
education secretary but he has time to
worry about
what the students of one college bear in
mind this is one college
in one university and busied himself
having a view on it this is an education
minister
with an unbelievably trivial
sensibility and i really think
we should be more worried about that
than we are okay well the graduates
uh the times tells us aim to replace the
portrait with art by
or of other influential and
inspirational people i just hope they
let us know who
um you've got 20 seconds mark metro
extension rebellion um
a demolition story tell us more
well i i should say i hope they replace
it with a portrait of zoe williams
obviously
but you know firstly this particular
headline extension with everyone great
work this
um it's only one side of the story but
allegedly this homeowner
um refused to pay an extra bill from his
builder who
decided to wreak vengeance with a digger
by ripping off the new roof
and ripping a huge hole in the extension
he'd built and leaving the chapter to
come home to find finally had
half a house oh dear talk more about
that perhaps we will see you very soon
top of the eleven
can't wait uh zoe mark thank you both
very much indeed for now let's take a
look at the weather